free speech and free thought that used
to be a liberal cause I mean that was
you know free speech UC Berkeley 1960s
we're gonna stand up and think and and
say whatever we want and you know the
comedian's of this 50s and 60s they're
pushing back against the man you know
the power authority which was mostly the
right and the Christian right and
Republicans and it was remember at the
time mostly Republicans mostly wanting
to censor things like burning the flag
or Madonna's videos or whatever because
their argument was well this could harm
society you know people expressing
themselves in a certain way can bring
down the moral values of our great
god-given you know whatever country and
therefore we have to combat that in a
way the left is now doing that saying
well you know certain speech is harmful
and harmful this is a form of violence
and there and we have to prevent
violence and therefore censoring
speeches okay that's kind of the the
thread I want to start with first always
just is just the title actually of the
book because that really struck me
giving the devil his due
it seems actually quite reverse of the
way that most of us behave these days
perhaps not the two of us right this
very moment but but so much of society
seems to be based on not giving the
devil his due just finding oh someone
thinks something differently than me
that must mean that everything they
think and the summation of who they are
is somehow evil and wrong so when you
came up with the title was that did that
have a lot to do with just sort of how
we seem to behave like right now yes
yeah I mean absolutely I'm just finding
that the page where I want to start on
this how this problem started because
free speech and free thought that used
to be a liberal cause I mean that was
you know free speech UC Berkeley 1960s
we're gonna stand up and think and and
say whatever we want and you know the
comedian's of this 50s and 60s they're
pushing back against the man you know
the power authority which was mostly the
right in the Christian Right and
Republicans and it was remember at the
time most Republicans mostly wanting to
censor things like burning the flag or
Madonna's videos or whatever
their argument was well this could harm
society you know people expressing
themselves in a certain way can bring
down the moral values of our great
god-given you know whatever country and
therefore we have to combat that in a
way the left is now doing that saying
well you know certain speech is harmful
and harmful this is a form of violence
and there and and we have to prevent
violence and therefore censoring speech
is okay that's kind of the the thread
and it really goes back I identify in
the first page of the book this goes
back to 1919 in the case of Schank
versus the United States so this is the
famous decision by this Supreme Court
justice Oliver Wendell Holmes where the
shouting fire in a theatre and clear and
present danger phrases come from so here
is his decision the most stringent
protection of free speech would not
protect a man in falsely shouting fire
in a theatre in causing a panic the
question in every case is whether the
words used are used in such
circumstances and are of such a nature
as to create a clear and present danger
that they will bring about substantive
evils that Congress has a right to
prevent okay what was this clear and
present danger
this guy shank was the head of the
Socialist Party in Philadelphia and he
was printing and handing out flyers to
draft age young men who were being
drafted
you know conscription was legal and they
were being drafted and sent to Europe to
die for our country and Schenk said wait
a minute that's a violation of the
Fourteenth Amendment which protects your
bodily autonomy and right and no one can
take away your life but in a way
conscription in the draft that that's a
way of the government saying we're
taking over your life for a while and
you may die if we order you to go do
that whoa okay now we can debate that
that's a separate issue the thing is how
can that be a clear and present danger
that's the equivalent of crash outing
fire in a crowded theater well now by
the 1960s of course everybody's
protesting the draft and burning their
draft cards and running up to Canada or
whatever and that was a liberal cause to
say you know what that that's going too
far you know it has to be okay to have
those kinds of debates and discussions
and protests that's all protected by the
Constitution here's the US Supreme Court
saying no no we can step in and okay so
fast-forward to say
the civil rights movement and the push
in the 70s and 80s to improve our speech
right okay so don't use the n-word you
know that it's really harmful okay
pretty much everybody go yeah yeah
that's that's right okay and by the way
the c-word for women and calling Jews
[ __ ] sand and Vietnamese gooks and that
the bin starts getting bigger and bigger
like yeah that's hateful it's so harmful
and and therefore it should be censored
so it starts off with good intentions on
the part of the left like yeah yeah
that's and that this moral progress
starts but then by the 90s you get you
know that the bin is getting larger and
then by you know a couple years ago when
I reprinted in there the UC systems list
of microaggressions that are harmful
hateful things to say things like where
are you from or wow you speak English so
well or why aren't you good at math or
you are gonna write you have a whole
chart laying this out yeah so you know
these things out but yeah so are you
surprised though the way the mission
creep has affected institutions that
were supposed to defend these liberal
principles I mean the easiest one I can
give you is nadine strossen who you have
the blurb on the back of the book she
was the head of the aclu she is a free
speech absolutist she no longer is the
head now she's since retired but she
laid out in this very room the very
strong case for why the Nazis should
have been allowed to march in Skokie
versal annoy it was a place where there
was a tremendous amount of Holocaust
survivors but the ACLU defended the
freedom of speech of a group of odious
people because that's what we're
supposed to do in this country we're now
even the ACLU is often suddenly
seemingly on the wrong side of these
things are you surprised but it's not
just affected individual people but the
way that the mission creep has affected
the institutions that were supposed to
stand up for this stuff that it has and
I'm worried about that I don't know if
they actually believe it or if they're
just scared that they're gonna be
cancelled and and censored themselves or
whatever you know I'm somewhat
sympathetic to some university
administrators say who kind of go along
with it because they're scared of losing
their jobs or professors are afraid to
say something but but but this
the problem they should this the whole
reason for tenure in the first place was
to protect liberal professors from these
right-wing coops who wanted to shut them
down now it's kind of reversed and so
maybe we do need tenure to protect these
liberal professors from their fellow
leftists or fellow liberals who want to
cancel them to shut them down get them
fired that this is a perverse reversal
of things that you know it's just gone
haywire I mean so the devil in the title
is whoever you disagree with and whoever
disagrees with you or you don't like or
you don't like what they say I mean it's
easy to grant free speech to people you
agree with that's know who it's for it's
for the people that that don't agree
with you those are the voices we have to
hear okay so to articulate the reasons
simply you know one person's hate speech
is another person's free speech so I got
this from nadine strossen book that in
the 1850s southern politicians argued
that abolitionists from the north coming
into the south to give sermons and
speeches and and distribute pamphlets
about the evils of slavery that's a form
of hate speech no they didn't use that
word hate speech but that basically made
the argument that Justice Holmes made
was that this could lead to slave diets
in insurrections and that could lead to
the murder of slave owners and the
disruption of our peaceful plantation
life here in the south and so therefore
we have to censor that it's like wow if
they hadn't had this opportunity to
champion the abolition of slavery would
we ever have gotten there and then in
the 1960s there were arguments in the
South again made against Malcolm X
particular and Martin Luther King
slightly less that what they were saying
was what was a they again didn't use the
word hate speech but that this is
potentially dangerous to have them
coming down here to give these sermons
and speeches that rile people up and
they go out in the streets to protest
wow we can't have that well they will
hate a minute that's how social change
happens and that's protected in the
Constitution and again these are liberal
causes that by now it's kind of flipped
so we have to remind ourselves trying to
do in this book is that no no here are
the reasons okay so I articulate them
like they did maybe
did on your show you know it's it's like
even if you're completely right you can
learn something from somebody else's
arguments to improve your own arguments
as John Stuart Mill said he who knows
his own side only his own side of the
case doesn't even know that right so
like I have my students watch Ben
Shapiro's videos arguing pro-life and
because most of them they don't know
what the pro-life arguments are and it's
like so even if you end up being
pro-choice at the end you still you're
better off now but but maybe Ben's right
about some points or whatever the other
side is maybe you're completely wrong
and you can learn something new but
mostly the devil part here is is for my
safety sake also that if once I setup
the norms or laws or customs or whatever
to silence you well what happens if I'm
now in the minority position or I have
the voice that that goes against the
grain then then I've I've already
endorsed the apparatus to shut me down
mm-hm so that's a that's the best
argument if you want to take it from
kind of a selfish perspective to give
the devil his due for your own safety
sake if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
academia instead of non-stop yelling
check out our academia playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist there all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell